ethiopia's prime minister abby ahmed has
announced that what he says would be a
final military operation against
uh tigre province after local leaders
ignored his surrender ultimatum
earlier the federal government carried
out what it called surgical air strikes
against tigre's regional capital
michaela the government has so far
resisted international pressure for
mediation in the conflict
but fallout from two weeks of fighting
has the potential to destabilize the
entire region
and has already started what the u.n
says is a full-scale
humanitarian crisis well kenya yadetta
is ethiopia's defense minister he joins
us from addis ababa
welcome to dw what does abi ahmed mean
by
a final military operation
well thank you very much uh the final
military operation refers to
enforcing the rule of law and
across the nation particularly targeting
on the tplf until group
who has been
violating rights in ethiopia
and highly corrupted groups therefore
uh the operation is going on and
is going to be completed probably
within a week seven days i suppose
what i'm really trying to get at is why
will this uh
final military operation what will be
different about this final military
operation
than all the other military operations
that preceded it
it means that there is a very short
period it
will be completed within a very short
period of time
because this group junta group
is really has massacred the civilians in
ethiopia
gross violation of rights and then
they investigated an ethnic conflict in
ethiopia
therefore it is the operation
is targeting these groups and
the final military operation means it
will be completed within a very short
period of time
and by complete do you what what do you
mean do you mean you will have bombed
them into surrender
yeah it means that these groups are
going to be
made under control and they face court
of law
so is if this mastermind or this junta
group
face justice or if they are made under
control
the operation will end and it is not a
civil war
but some propagate that the conflict
going on in ethiopia is
a kind of civil war but it's not
a civil war but it's about ensuring rule
of law
targeting very very very few
groups why is the ethiopian government
unwilling to accept
external mediation
well this is an internal affair and it
doesn't need
external uh institutions
or nations to intervene in ethiopia and
sovereignty
because it is a matter of internal
affair
except it's not internal is it because
it's already affecting
sudan as tens of thousands of refugees
pour out of ethiopia
and it's affecting eritrea to the north
as
rockets are launched into that region so
this is no longer
ah an internal matter for ethiopia
we defined the concept of internal
affair
that the issue is not between
independent
nation tegra is not independent nation
it is a it is a regional one of the
regional states in ethiopia
therefore we cannot define it
as as a conflict going on between
different independent countries it is
going on
in the internal matter and
it's internal issue in any way okay so
ethiopia
will not accept external mediation and
will also
not allow aid agencies into the country
or
journalists into the country same
question
why
well i am just i've
told you that this is the issue related
to the sovereignty
or internal affairs so and also it
doesn't
take uh many many times
it is it's really be going to be
completed within a week
therefore we don't consider it it is a
big deal it's
a something uh internal matter
so he the united nations um begs to
differ with you the united nations
thinks this is a big deal
the united nations has described this as
being on the verge of a humanitarian
catastrophe
well practically this is not
this is untrue in ethiopia
the ethiopian military force
are professionals and they target on the
on the groups the junta group not the
civilians or
some other social infrastructures the
target the focus is
on specifically that may be the theory
it may be that that is what you wish to
happen that these are focused
attacks but the the united nations says
um
this this is on the verge of being a
full-scale
humanitarian crisis do you not recognize
that the carnage that is going on on the
ground
no i don't think uh really we are
so much uh we would give a
taker for such issues and i don't
feel that that can happen and because
this very in a very short time will
finish all the operation and
we are such we don't have such such
a fear so how short is this time in
which this operation will be completed
when do you expect
this uh this final operation to start
and to end
yes it is going on now and this junta
group has been
encircled in all directions and
we have planned to complete it probably
within less than 10 to 15 days
and what will victory uh look like in
this uh
conflict it is not a matter of victory
but
it's a matter of ensuring rule of law
and bringing this junta group was a
court of law
it's not the kind of victory it's about
ensuring the rule of law
so so again when will it finish then
will it finish when you arrest people
when when when they surrender when
everyone is dead
when will it finish they should
surrender
and they should just give their hands to
the army
so if they are willing to surrender
the operation will be completed
thank you for joining us uh kenya
yadatta
defence minister of ethiopia
thank you very much
you